In general, we can use the empirical
counts of events in the observed data
to estimate probabilities.
and a commonly used technique is called
a maximum likelihood estimate, where we
simply normalize the observed accounts.
So if we do that, we can see we can
compute these probabilities as follows
for estimating the probability that we
see a word occurring in segment, we
simply normalize the counts of segments
that contain this word.
So let's first take a look at the data
here.
On the right side you see I listed some
hypothesizes that data these are
segments.
And in some segments you see both words
occur.
Their indicator as once for both
columns.
In some other cases, only one word
occurs, so only that column has one and
the other column has zero.
And of course in some other cases, none
of the words occur, so they are both
zeros.
And
For estimating these probabilities, we
simply need to collect the three
counts.
So the three counts of 1st, the count
of W.
1 and that's the total number of
segments that contain world W one.
It's just the ones in the column of W
one we can just count how many ones we
have seen there.
The second counter is for word 2 and we
just count the ones in the second
column.
And these this would give us a total
number of segments that contain W2.
The third account is when both words
occurred, so this is time we're going
to count the segments where both
columns have ones.
And then so this would give us the
total number of segments where we have
seen both W and W2.
Once we have these counts, we can just
normalize.
These counts by n, which is the total
number of segments and this will give
us the probabilities that we need to
compute mutual information.
Now there is a small problem.
When we have zero counts sometimes and
in this case we don't want a zero
probability because our data maybe a
small sample and in general we would
believe that it's potentially possible
for award to occur in any context.
So to address this problem we can use a
technique called smoothing and that's
basically to add some small constant to
discounts and then so that we don't get
a zero probability in any case.
Now, the best way to understand the
smoothing is imagine that we actually.
Observed more data than we actually
have.
We will pretend we observe some pseudo
segments that are illustrated on the
top on the right side of the slide and
these pseudo segments would contribute
additional counts of these words so
that no event will have zero
probability probability.
Now, in particular, we introduce the
four pseudo segments.
Each is weighted 1/4.
And these represent the four different
combinations of occurrences of these
words.
So now each event, each combination
will have at least one count or at
least non zero counter.
From these pseudo segment.
So in the actual segments that we
observed, it's OK if we haven't
observed all the combinations.
So more specifically, you can see the
point of five.
Here actually comes from the two ones
in the two pseudo segments, because
each is weighted 1/4, we added them up.
We get .5.
And similarly this .05 comes from one
single pseudo segment that indicates
the two words occur together.
And of course, in the denominator we
add the total number of pseudo segments
that we added.
In this case we added a 4th through the
segments.
Each is weighted 1/4, so the total the
sum is actually one.
So that's why in the denominator you
still want there.
So this basically concludes the
discussion of how to compute the mutual
information, how to use this for
syntagmatic relation discovery.
No.
So, to summarize, select the cinematic
relation can generally be discovered by
measuring correlations between
occurrences of two words.
We introduce the three concepts from
information theory, entropy, which
meshes uncertainly over random variable
X conditional entropy, which measures
the entropy of X.
Given we know why.
And mutual information of X&Y which
matches the entropy reduction of X.
Due to knowing why or entropy reduction
of why do too knowing eggs?
They are the same, so these three
concepts are actually very useful for
other applications as well.
That's why we spend some time to
explain this in detail, but in
particular there also very useful for
discovering syntagmatic relations.
In particular, mutual information is a
principled way for discovering such a
relation.
It allows us to have values computer on
different pairs of words that are
comfortable, and so we can rank these
pairs and discover the strongest
cinematical relationship from
collection of documents.
Now note that there is some relation
between syntactic medical relation
discovery and paradigmatically relation
discovery.
So we already discussed the possibility
of using BM 25 to achieve waiting for
terms in the context to potentially
also suggest the candidates that have
seen like medical relations with the
candidate word.
But here, once we use mutual
information to discover Syntagmatic
relations, we can also represent the
context with this mutual information as
weights.
So this would give us another way to
represent the context.
Of a word like a cat, and if we do the
same for all the words, then we can
cluster these words or computer
similarity between these words based on
their context similarity.
So this provides yet another way to do
term waiting for paradigmatic.
A relation discovery an.
So to summarize, this whole part about
word Association mining, we introduce
the two basic associations, called
Paradigmatic and Syntagmatic relations.
These are fairly general.
They can be applied to any items in any
language, so the units don't have to be
worse than they can be phrases or
entities.
Are we introduced multiple statistical
approaches for discovering them?
Then it showing that pure statistical
approaches are visible?
Available for discovering both kinds of
relations, and they can be combined to
perform.
Join the analysis as well.
These approaches can be applied to any
text with no helmet human effort.
And mostly becausw.
They are based on counting of words.
Yet they can actually discover
interesting relations of words.
We can also use different ways to
define context and segment and this
would lead to some interesting
variations of applications.
For example, the context can be very
narrow, like a few words around a word
or sentence or maybe paragraphs and
using different contexts, which allows
you to discover different flavors of
paradigmatic relations.
And similarly, counting Co occurrences
using, let's say mutual information to
discover syntagmatic relations, we also
have to define the segment and the
segment can be defined as an arrow,
text window or longer text article and
this would give us different kinds of
associations.
These discovery associations can
support them.
Any other applications in both
information retrieval and text data
mining.
So here are some recommended readings.
If you want to know more about the
topic, the 1st is a book with a chapter
on locations which is quite relevant to
the topic of these lectures.
The second is the article about the
using various statistical measures to
discover lexical atoms.
Those are phrases that are non
composition compositional or for
example hot dog is not really a dog
that's hot.
Blue chip is not a chip that's blue,
and the paper has a discussion about to
some techniques for discovering such
phrases.
The third one is new paper on unified
way to discover both paradigmatic a
relation and select medical relations
using random walks on world graphs.